passte all Limone ist eins der
einfachsten Nudelgerichte die ich kenne
wir brauchen lediglich Bio-Zitronen
dünsten ein bisschen Knoblauch in
Olivenöl an geben dann Nudelwasser dazu
und außerdem noch Chili und dann kommt
noch Salz und Zitronensaft mit hinein
das Rezept ist in unter 10 Minuten
fertig und ganz traditionell geben wir
noch Spaghetti mit dazu die ich vorab
gar gekocht habe frische Basilikum
Blätter dürfen nicht fehlen und wenn es
ganz traditionell möchte dann gibt
Parmesankäse oben drauf immer wenn ich
kein Parmesankäse da habe dann nehme ich
Hefeflocken denn das ist die vegane
Parmesan Alternative